The leading generals of World War Two carried
a huge weight on their shoulders.
Their decisions could mean the difference
between life and death for thousands of men;
their actions helped to shape the fate of
nations.
History has judged some of them as fools,
others as butchers, and a handful as military
geniuses...
Few, at least on the Allied side, have generated
as much controversy in life and death in as
George S Patton.
The flamboyant American commander never lost
a major battle, but his explosive temper almost
cost him his career.
He survived two World Wars, often placing
himself in considerable danger, only to die
in unlikely circumstances within months of
Germany’s defeat.
The unconventional general was a devout Christian,
yet he believed he was just the latest incarnation
of a warrior spirit who’d once fought alongside
the likes of Julius Caesar and Napoleon Bonaparte.
He was the epitome of the rough, tough warrior
who reveled in his macho image and seemingly
lived only for war.
But he could be a surprisingly sensitive individual
who cried at funerals and penned poetry1 throughout
much of his life.
In this Biographics video we are going to
dive right into the details of this mans life.
“The object of war is not to die for your
country but to make the other bastard die
for his.”
- George S Patton
Early Life
George S Patton was in born in California
on November 11, 1885.
Twenty years earlier the Patton family had
lost much of their wealth when they found
themselves on the losing side of America’s
civil war.
However, by the time of George’s birth the
Patton’s were prosperous and influential
once again.
The young George knew from an early age that
he wanted to be a soldier.
His main obstacles were his weaknesses in
maths and English.
This was not a result of any lack of natural
ability, but rather because his father’s
mistrust of formal education meant that George
hadn’t attended school until he reached
twelve years of age.
He caught up quickly but only narrowly passed
the entrance exam for West Point, America’s
most prestigious military academy.
While Patton would regularly clash with his
superiors during World War II, his conduct
at West Point was exemplary.
He was particularly successful at sports such
as polo and football, playing with such relentless
aggression that he broke several bones.
He would later bring this aggression to his
method of waging war.
Olympic Games
Patton’s considerable sporting ability did
not go unnoticed, and he was selected to represent
2 the United States of America in the Modern
Pentathlon at the 1912 Stockholm Olympic Games.
He would compete at riding, shooting, fencing,
running and swimming, all things that Patton
excelled at.
Interestingly, in the event it was Patton’s
shooting that may have let him down.
He fired twenty bullets, but the judges ruled
that three of them had missed the target.
Patton remained adamant that his aim had actually
been too good and his shots had passed through
the hole he had already made in the bullseye.
It’s possible he was correct, but the judges
ruled against him.
At the end of the first day Patton was placed
in a slightly disappointing 21st from 41 competitors.
Strong performances in each of the remaining
events saw him climb all the way to fifth
place.
It was the first and last time he competed
in the Olympic Games, but he didn’t have
to wait long to test the accuracy of his shooting
in a combat situation…
Bandit Hunting
By 1916 most of the world’s great powers
were locked together in seemingly interminable
combat.
Only the United States had thus far succeeded
in avoiding being drawn into the slaughter.
However, America did suffer a surprise attack
from the direction of Mexico.
On 9 March 1916 four-hundred heavily-armed
bandits led by the notorious Francisco “Pancho”
Villa stormed across the border.
For two hours they ransacked and looted the
border town of Columbus, before finally being
chased away by the cavalry.
If Villa believed he could hide out safely
back in Mexico, he was sorely mistaken.
President Woodrow Wilson ordered the US Army
to cross the border and put an end to the
threat posed by Villa and his bandits.
John Pershing 3 was given command of the expeditionary
force, and he chose Patton to serve as his
aide.
Patton would go on to become famous for his
skill at commanding fast-moving motorized
forces, so it’s perhaps fitting that while
in Mexico he took part in the first motorized
action in the history of warfare 4.
Travelling in three Dodge Touring cars, Patton
and his men launched a raid on Villa’s henchmen.
When the smoke cleared at the end of a brief
firefight, three of Villa’s bodyguards lay
dead.
Patton ordered their bodies to be strapped
to the cars for the drive back to headquarters.
Pershing was apparently impressed, reportedly
saying: “This Patton boy, he’s a real
fighter!”
World War I
On 6 April 1917 the United States of America
declared war on Germany and entered World
War One.
Pershing was given command of the American
Expeditionary Force, and once again he took
George Patton at his side.
Not content to serve as an aide for long,
Patton pushed to be given a command of his
own.
Pershing offered him an infantry battalion
but by that time Patton had become fascinated
by tanks - powerful yet unreliable weapons
still in their infancy since being unleashed
by the British at the Somme in September of
1916.
Patton became the first officer assigned to
the American Expeditionary Force Tank Corps,
was one of the first Americans to learn how
to operate a tank, and personally taught the
first crews to be assigned to the Tank Corps.
The American Expeditionary Force Tank Corps
finally went into action in September 1918,
with Patton riding into battle clinging onto
the outside of one of the machines.
Later that same month he would be badly injured
in an act of near-suicidal bravery.
World War I tanks were seriously underpowered,
unreliable, and vulnerable without infantry
support.
So when his tanks became isolated during the
Meuse-Argonne Offensive 5, Patton called for
volunteers to help him storm the German lines.
Only five men stepped forward.
They were quickly cut down by a hail of German
bullets.
Patton himself was badly injured by a piece
of shrapnel which hit him in the thigh.
He continued to direct the battle from a shell
hole, he later refused medical treatment until
he had completed and submitted his report.
Patton’s injuries weren’t life threatening,
but they were serious.
By the time he had recovered sufficiently
to return to combat the armistice had been
signed and the guns
fallen silent.
While Patton’s time at the frontlines had
been brief, he had done more than enough to
demonstrate that he possessed the kind of
raw courage he expected and demanded of those
who served under him.
Between the Wars
With the Great War at an end Patton returned
to the United States of America where he found
a good deal to keep him busy.
He learned to fly, drove the latest automobiles,
sailed his yacht, mixed with high society,
kept a stable of horses, and won hundreds
of trophies and ribbons in numerous sporting
events.
Such an extravagant lifestyle would ordinarily
be well out of reach on a major’s salary.
However, in 1910 Patton had married Beatrice
Ayer, the extremely wealthy heiress of a Boston
industrialist.
The Pattons had more than enough money to
do almost anything they wanted, but George
had never wavered from his belief that he
was destined to be a great soldier.
He maintained a special interest in armored
warfare, and some visionaries were proclaiming
that tanks would become the decisive weapon
in any future conflict.
Heinz Guderian in Germany and Charles de Gaulle
in France argued that tanks would return mobility
to the battlefield, punching through enemy
positions to create havoc in the rear.
Patton was thinking along similar lines, and
he got the chance to test out some of his
ideas in 1941 when the US Army held vast wargames
6 across the states of Louisiana and Carolina.
More than 400,000 soldiers and 1,000 aircraft
took part in mock battles held over 30,000
square miles.
With Germany once again at war with Britain
and Russia, and no guarantees that America
would be able to remain neutral, it was a
much needed opportunity to test out tactics
and equipment.
It also served as a test of the men who would
lead America’s armies into battle.
The battles weren’t real, but they were
a close enough approximation for sixty-one
men to lose their lives.
However, despite these losses, the US Army
gained valuable experience, and Patton staked
his claim to be arguably the US Army’s finest
exponent of armored warfare.
Africa
On 7 December 1941 Japan attacked the United
States of America at Pearl Harbor.
Four days later Germany declared war on America.
And with that World War II became a truly
global war.
With plans for a 1942 Allied invasion of Western
Europe having been shelved, the Allied High
Command instead chose to strike at Hitler’s
Vichy French allies in North Africa.
Three separate task forces were launched,
with General George Patton taking command
of 35,000 men of the Western Task Force, sailing
for Casablanca from Virginia.
If Patton had any fears or doubts, he certainly
wasn’t showing them, and he wrote in his
diary:
“When I realize what I am, I am amazed,
but on reflection, who is as good as I am?
I know of no one 7.”
Modest too…
The amphibious landings of 8 November were
largely unopposed, and despite some fierce
resistance as Patton’s men pushed inland,
the Vichy French signed an armistice later
that day.
Far more formidable than the French, however,
was Germany’s Erwin Rommel and his Afrika
Korps.
On 14 February 1943 they attacked in force,
striking at US forces in Tunisia’s Atlas
Mountains.
By the 20th February the immediate crisis
was over, but the Americans had been pushed
back 50 miles.
Huge amounts of equipment had been abandoned,
and 4,000 Americans, including Patton’s
own son-in-law, had been captured by the Germans.
With morale on the floor, Eisenhower sacked
the commander he held responsible and placed
all American troops in Tunisia under Patton’s
command.
Patton immediately subjected his men to an
intensive drill routine and a strict disciplinary
code.
His methods were far from universally popular,
but they got results and within a month Patton
was on the offensive defeating the formidable
German 10th Panzer Division at the Battle
of El Guettar 8.
Patton rapidly built a reputation for himself
in North Africa, but it was here that he began
his rivalry with Bernard Montgomery, the commander
of the British Eighth Army.
While Patton was bold, aggressive, and often
acted on gut instinct, Montgomery was by nature
a far more cautious man who put great stock
in meticulous planning.
Patton believed Eisenhower deferred to Montgomery
far too often, a feeling that was only strengthened
when the British commander was given the go-ahead
to plan the invasion of Sicily...
Sicily and Scandal
The invasion of Sicily was to be a joint operation
conducted by the British Eighth Army led by
Montgomery and the Seventh US Army commanded
by George Patton.
Much to Patton’s disgust, Montgomery’s
plan placed the main emphasis on the British
contingent and cast the Americans in the supporting
role.
“This is what you get,” fumed Patton,
“when your commander-in-chief (Eisenhower)
ceases to be an American and becomes an ally.”
The invasion force landed on the beaches of
Sicily on 10 July 1943.
By nightfall the Allies had put 80,000 men
and 300 tanks ashore.
The next day Patton himself came to inspect
the beachhead, wading in through the surf
even as artillery shells exploded around the
beach.
While it soon became clear that the Germans
would not be able to hold Sicily, they fought
a fierce rear-guard action as they began to
evacuate their army to the Italian mainland.
As Montgomery’s army became bogged down,
Patton decided to take a loose interpretation
of his orders.
He was expected to support the British, but
surely the best way to do so would be to hit
the Germans hard.
Patton drove the Seventh Army on, his goal
now was to beat Montgomery to the city of
Messina in the north of the island.
He was driven not just by personal ambition,
but by a desire to prove the American soldier
was the best in the world...
The Sicily campaign 9 was fought at a blistering
pace in blazing heat; casualties were inevitable…
On 3 August 1943 Patton visited the wounded
at a field hospital.
When he discovered that one of the patients
was physically unhurt but suffering from shellshock,
he exploded with rage.
Patton slapped the unfortunate man, dragged
him from the tent, kicked him in the backside,
and threatened to shoot him for cowardice.
Unfortunately for Patton, this extraordinary
display had been conducted under the noses
of a number of journalists.
Patton didn’t seem to realize he’d done
anything wrong, but striking a subordinate
was a court martial offence.
Eisenhower ordered Patton to apologise, begged
the witnesses not to report on the incident,
and hoped that would be enough to protect
his most dangerous weapon in the war against
the Nazis.
While Patton won his race to Messina and threw
the Nazis out of Sicily, his vicious temper
came back to bite him as word of his assault
leaked out in the press.
There was little more that Eisenhower could
do.
Patton was removed from his command; and with
that it seemed as if his career might be over…
Operation Overlord
The invasion of Italy followed on almost as
a natural consequence of the conquest of Sicily.
Patton, who was ill-suited to inactivity,
could only watch on in frustration.
Of even greater importance than the campaign
in Italy was the long-awaited invasion of
Western Europe.
This would take place in June of 1944.
It was one of the most difficult operations
of the war, but Patton would have no direct
role to play in the invasion...
Instead he was used as a decoy, given command
of an entirely fictitious army 10 intended
to fool the Germans into believing that a
second invasion force was preparing to strike.
The ruse totally worked.
The Germans never imagined that the Allies
would leave their best offensive general back
in Britain while such a vital offensive was
being fought in France…
Breakout
Patton’s greatest fear was that the war
would be over before he could get back into
it.
He needn’t have worried though...
While the success of the initial Allied invasion
exceeded expectations, the British and Americans
made slow progress as they attempted to push
inland.
It wasn’t until the end of July that the
Americans finally punched a small hole through
German lines.
Omar Bradley, commander of the US ground forces,
knew that this was the moment to get Patton
back in the fray.
Bradley regarded Patton as difficult to control,
unpredictable, and vulgar, but he recognized
his talents.
Patton was given command of the newly formed
Third Army, a highly mobile force equipped
with plenty of armor.
He was ordered to go and break through the
German lines…
Patton quickly got to work, squeezed his armored
divisions through the narrowest of gaps in
the German lines, reformed them on the other
side, and within a matter of days his Third
Army was tearing through open country into
Brittany.
The speed of Patton’s advances often worried
his superiors, since he was a risk taker who
rarely worried about the danger of an attack
to his flanks.
Hitler himself thought he had sniffed out
an opportunity to exploit the Allied breakout,
launch a counterattack, and cut off Patton’s
armored spearheads.
Now this idea did have its merits in theory,
but the German Army lacked the strength to
execute the operation in practice...
It was instead the Germans who found themselves
in danger of being completely encircled at
Falaise 11.
Patton believed he was in a position to slam
the jaws of the trap shut.
Bradley, a far more cautious commander than
Patton, ordered the Third Army to halt at
Argentan.
Patton was furious but complied with the order,
even though he suspected Bradley had been
influenced by Montgomery...
Race to the Rhine and the Battle of the Bulge
Hitler’s failed counterattack led to the
near collapse of the German Army in France.
With that, Patton was free to launch his blitzkrieg
assault.
His philosophy was relentless attack and unrelenting
pressure that kept the enemy constantly off
balance and minimized the Third Army’s casualties.
Patton argued that if he was properly backed
he could be across the River Rhine in a matter
of weeks.
But he once again found himself in competition
with Montgomery as each man attempted to secure
enough supplies to keep their army moving.
As Patton complained, “My men can eat their
belts, but my tanks have gotta have gas.”
Although there were still disagreements amongst
the leading Allied generals, they were united
in the belief that Hitler’s armies were
all but beaten.
Germany’s Fuhrer, however, had one last
surprise in store.
On 16 December 1944 the Germans launched a
vast counterattack aimed at a thinly held
section of the American lines at the Ardennes.
This was the beginning of the battle that
would become famous as the Battle of the Bulge.
The sudden, furious assault badly rattled
most Allied commanders, but Patton recognized
at once that Hitler had made a serious strategic
error.
“Let the sons of bitches go all the way
to Paris if they like,” he joked, “then
we can really cut them off and chew them up.”
Eisenhower summoned his senior commanders
to an emergency conference, where he asked
how long it would take Patton to divert his
Third Army to the Ardennes.
Patton told him he could have three divisions
there within 48 hours.
This seemingly fantastical claim was met with
a mixture of laughter and disbelieving stares,
but Patton was entirely serious.
He’d anticipated Eisenhower’s request
and his staff were already making preparations
to disengage the part of the Third Army, wheel
it around, and race to the rescue 12 along
narrow icy roads.
The Battle of the Bulge gave the Allied High
Command a shock, but as Patton had predicted
it accomplished nothing and cost Hitler his
last reserves.
Now the River Rhine was the last significant
obstacle the Western Allies had to tackle.
The main crossing was to be launched by Montgomery,
and he spent two months planning every last
detail of the operation, which called for
an airborne assault, a huge artillery bombardment,
and even the assistance of specialized US
Navy vessels.
Montgomery’s crossing was launched on 23rd
March, by which time Patton had already stolen
his thunder by quietly sneaking a division
across under cover of darkness and establishing
a bridgehead on the other side.
He phoned Bradley to let him know what he’d
done: “But don’t tell anyone because the
krauts haven’t realized yet.”
Controversial in Life and Death
With the defeat of Germany, Patton tried and
failed to secure a posting to the Far East
to play a part in the war against Japan.
Instead he was appointed as Governor of Bavaria,
a political post to which he was not well
suited.
He fell out with the Russians, refused to
remove Nazi personnel from key administrative
positions on the basis that there was nobody
else qualified to do the job, and got tricked
by a reporter into agreeing Nazis joined their
party in more-or-less the same way as Americans
became Democrats or Republicans.
Patton’s military abilities were not matched
by his political instincts, and he had once
again succeeded in outraging the press.
His subsequent apology was deemed insufficient
and he was removed from his post for the second
time.
But at this point, although he didn’t know
it, he only had a few months left to live…
On 9 December 1945 Patton was being driven
towards a hunting expedition when the vehicle
he was travelling in was struck by a truck
travelling in the opposite direction.
Nobody else was hurt, but Patton was paralyzed
from the neck down.
The injured general was rushed to hospital
where he died eleven days later.
He was buried in Europe alongside the fallen
soldiers of his beloved Third Army.
Patton had always wanted to die in battle,
instead he’d lost his life as a result of
a low speed collision in peacetime.
Not everybody accepts the official version
of Patton’s demise.
It has been suggested that Patton may have
been assassinated 13 by the Russians, possibly
even in collusion with the US Government,
as a result of his outspoken opposition to
the Soviet Union.
He was 60 years old.